♪I can't keep quiet ♪
- [Connie] It's really incredible
to watch something become
bigger than myself.
I used to call Quiet my song.
Quiet is now our song.
My name is Connie Lim
and I go by MILCK as a recording artist
and I think my job is to help heal people.
(upbeat strings)
I got involved with music
by playing piano and singing
and writing my first song at age seven.
My mission with my music
is to empower and to heal.
I used to have an eating disorder
and I am a product of abuse,
and so when I wrote songs
I was able to digest some
of my pain.
I'm constantly chasing the high
of writing a song that makes
me feel like I can breathe more.
My song, Quiet, is about
that gentle rage that I felt
whenever I felt stereotyped,
or oppressed, or controlled,
or even when I was doing it to myself.
I went to D.C. to participate
in the D.C. Women's March
and I recruited a bunch of
women who lived in the D.C. area
to sing my song with me.
♪I can't keep quiet ♪
When we were singing
on the streets of D.C.,
we did seven flash mobs.
And, I thought to myself,
this is my calling,
my calling is to facilitate
these groups of women to come
together and sing together
because singing can create
endless bonds.
♪I can't keep quiet ♪
Within two days the video
of us performing had
14 million views.
My life is completely changed.
I've signed with Atlantic Records.
I get messages from women all
over the world saying that
when they can't get out of
bed, they'll play the song
so they get out of bed.
I think that's amazing.
I'm definitely going to
continue down this path
because it's so fulfilling
and so empowering for me
and for other people.
I'm empowering women
and men and all genders in between
and helping people heal,
and that's exactly what my purpose is.